[Music]
divinity original sin - is a game full
of choices you have to decide where to
go who to talk to what to say and whose
house to ransack after you kill the
owner and use a tool to rip their face
off and create a mask for an undead
creature but before getting into any of
the real action you'll have choices of a
different sort to make mainly what class
to play much like its predecessor
original sin - lets you choose a premade
character or completely customize one
it's important to realize that no matter
what decisions you make on the outset of
your journey you'll be able to reshape
your character over the course of the
game you'll also at one point have the
opportunity to rebuild your character
from scratch if you regret your
decisions but that doesn't mean the
choices you make at the start don't
matter original sin - can be a very
difficult game from the get-go and
you'll want to make sure you have a
capable character to play with choosing
one of the default options and then
modding it in the opening hours is a
safer path than building one completely
from scratch so in this video we're
going to examine each of the default
classes and potential skills you may
want to substitute
battle mages are a solid blend of
close-range melee combat and elemental
damage has to be expected from a class
that isn't devoted to any one function
it doesn't excel in either category but
battle mages are all about versatility
by default battle mages like any ranged
moves that keep them out of danger
battering rams puts you right in the
middle of the action and both blind
radiance and shocking touch require you
to be close to your targets you can swap
out shocking touch in favour of electric
discharge or bouncing shield if you're
desperate to be able to deal damage at a
distance but battle mages are best
suited for being right in the thick of
things
[Music]
cleric focuses on healing magic and
close-range combat and it uses the
restoration ability for a traditional
healing spell it relies on the
necromancer skills to deal damage and
provide further healing both for the
cleric and their allies the cleric is
all about healing
so you'd be best off leaving the default
skills as is
[Music]
conjurer's rely on summoning to deal the
bulk of their damage while this does
leave them with few options in terms of
direct offense the ability to provide
additional targets to distract your
enemies can be invaluable condors are
best off sticking with the default set
of skills there is only one other choice
Farsight infusion which provides magic
armor and a ranged attack for your
summoned incarnate but early on this is
not worth the trade-off of losing your
ability to deal damage with dimensional
bolt or the presence and damage of your
totem of which you can have more than
one out at a time wizard is a
traditional magic user where they focus
on damage dealing by default you'll have
pyrokinetic and geomancer skills which
combined well together use fossil strike
to create in oil surface and then light
it ablaze with ignition as an
alternative you can swap out fossil
strike in favor of contamination which
creates a poison surface that can still
be combined with ignition
[Music]
like the wizard the enchanter is a
Street magic user but rather than
focusing on pure damage-dealing they
channel spells that effect enemies and
the battlefield around them despite
sounding relatively innocuous Rayne is
one of the most useful spells in the
game as it can put out fires which
happens way more often than it should in
battle it also pairs well with the
enchanters other spells as making an
opponent wet leaves them more
susceptible to being shocked with a
spell like electric discharge what
surfaces or enemies can also be frozen
with hail strike it's a very
self-sustaining class and pairs with
other classes well considering how
important elemental effects are the
enchanter is easily one of the best
classes despite the name fighters serve
primarily as tanks they start with more
health thanks to the +2 Constitution and
come equipped with fortify which
restores physical armor and ensures they
aren't teleported away from their
position on the frontlines
although tempting you should likely keep
both warfare and geomancer to start with
rather than investing in retribution
which reflects a percentage of damage
back at attackers
inquisitors are similar to battle mages
and that they are a blend of close-range
combat and elemental damage however
mosquito swarm presents them with a way
to deal damage from afar while
necromancer in general provides a means
for self-sustaining as they regain
health as they deal damage directly to
an enemy's health battering ram is
useful for getting into action while
crippling blow is a strong alternative
thanks to its ability to do significant
damage to nearby enemies Knights are a
more offensive oriented version of the
fighter relying heavily on close-range
damage they need to be in the thick of
things in order to deal damage and
you'll want to ensure you don't deviate
from the default skills
the only alternative with the standard
setup is bouncing shield but Knights
come with a point in two-handed weapons
meaning you shouldn't be using a shield
this is a textbook example of ensuring
you're aware of what each aspect of your
character involves in order to maximize
their effectiveness
metamorph tsar among the most
challenging classes to start out with if
you're new to the genre you're likely
better off trying something else first
as entertaining as metamorph may sound
chicken claw is a powerful ability but
it's essential that you pick out the
correct target as it can only be used
once every six turns the only
alternative skill available by default
is chameleon cloak which turns you
invisible
[Music]
the Ranger is a powerful mix of ranged
physical and elemental damage their bow
or crossbow lets them stay at a safe
distance which is important as to want
to maintain high ground to take
advantage of the bonus damage provided
by Huntsman Rangers are versatile in
terms of elemental damage thanks to
their ability to craft various types of
elemental arrows alternatively the
elemental arrowheads scale provides a
way to temporarily unleash a wide
variety of elemental attacks depending
on what's nearby if you're looking for
additional healing you can swap out one
of the Huntsman skills in favour of
first aid additionally it's important to
note that ranged attacks in divinity
original sin 2 are much more reliable
than in the first game don't let your
experience with original sin scare you
off from giving the Ranger a try
[Music]
now if the idea of being a ranger
appeals to you but you want even more
flexibility wayfarer maybe for you
fossil strike allows you to create an
oil surface and if you have fire nearby
elemental arrowheads can be used to
ignite it and deal serious damage
following up with the skill pinned down
the following turn can allow you to
ensure the enemy is stuck in the ensuing
blaze or you can always swap it out in
favor of first aid to provide your party
with another source of healing rogues
rely on stealth and mobility to get
behind their opponents and backstab them
to deal maximum damage they're reliant
on others to heal them and thus
vulnerable if caught out of position
rogues can be a challenge to play
effectively but if you decide to try it
be sure to leave the default skills
alone chloroform
which puts the enemy to sleep is
tantalizing but the three pre-selected
options ensure you can maximize your
damage and have the flexibility to get
away
shadow blades are effectively spell
casting roads moving around quietly and
backstabbing enemies while maintaining
the freedom to turn an opponent into a
chicken every now and then like rogues
they are challenging to play while
lacking the additional health that
rogues enjoy but their +2 to wit's
ensures that they'll be able to act more
often than most other characters a
short-range spell caster which is deal
heavy damage but are potentially
vulnerable their damage is also largely
indirect outside a backstabbing foes
you'll need a dead body and some time to
move a bloated corpse into position to
explode positioning is incredibly
important with witches making this one
of the more challenging classes to start
out with remember to think about these
skills when picking party members as
well although you won't be able to
substitute skills for them being stuck
with the defaults it's also important to
remember that these classes are simply
the starting base and over time your
character will grow and shift into their
own unique snowflake that sucks up blood
and grows wings
now that you've crafted the perfect
skeleton boy and are ready to play why
not check out our tips on things you
need to do in the game's opening area
fort joy and of course as always thanks
for watching
[Music]